okay hi everyone I'm Ricardo m h i Came
From Italy I'm a dater at aab aab is a
company that makes uh Big Data data mesh
Elite data engering what we say it's
that Jour is just not a little rule it's
a big rule so we we try try to make big
dat architecture for company we will
also have a a product is we boost that
create data MH
solution um yeah remote work yes as
always so today we will talk about um
very simple uh pipeline a data
manipulation pipeline is everyone that
works with data science machine learning
dat engineer they make pipeline so uh
it's normal based data pipeline so you
you start with a data ingestion we make
data manipulation and we make serving so
we extracted data load it in a SQL DB
for Tableau or Stu like this we want to
use a mod data stack we are 2023 and uh
it's cool it's to cool to to make to use
cool technology so we use zake for the
data wehous that storage computation DBT
because it's a SQL it's very easy to
take we can just say to the business
analytics to is it because they know SQL
and uh it's they have many plugins for
data manipulation and stuff like this
and I flow I flow because it's a
pipeline
orchestrator but imagine that you are
the data General stuff what whatever you
you you are doing your Ru and uh the man
say okay uh the consumer say that the
data quality is not consistent the data
is not good uh there are some fail there
are some error there are
something the data enger is do this is
the daily job of a data enginer normal
day so what do you do we have different
tools we have SN fake you check the the
data on the SN fake from the data source
to the staging layer silver bronze gold
everything you check check DBT logs on
S3 or dashboard whatever you want you
check it and analyze you go to air flow
you check where the pipeline fail you go
to the logs of a flow and Cloud watch or
what grafana whatever you
want if the iflow web interface it works
sometimes doesn't
work so many tools too many it's burnout
we will go in Burnout every day if you
go in this
direction
so there is a
problem there is a problem to Define
what is the pipeline and what is thata
pipeline so a pipeline orchestrator it's
a pipeline orator it's just execute
commands task function nothing nothing
especially just task just if you want to
make Linux or deploy ment it's it's a
pipeline
orchestrator okay ATL data integration I
just aggregate it if someone had don't
be shine with me uh ATL are design
partner framework like pandas for
example spark or whatever you want uh
talend is data integration tool so you
can
create uh pipeline move data from point
A to point B transforming etc etc a by
the same the same things data pipeline
it's a different s concept it's a
different concept because we want to
understand what happen on the data what
is the transformation of the data we
want to also to come back to make make
Fields maybe we want to partition the
data we want to make to understand which
is the life cycle of the data okay so we
have daxer and we have Luigi
so as just explained I flow there they
have many problems if you just go to Aur
news there is an issue open with a
thousand of comments of I have problem
in production that the web interface is
not working I don't can scale the the
flow etc etc stuff like this and from my
experience there is also problem in how
to use flow I mean there is operator
someone is contributing in this operator
I don't know which one is contributing
it's who is the maintainer of the
operator I don't know maybe airflow
maybe uh the the integrator I don't know
about this there is a operator but many
of times we do custom operator because
it's difficult to
handle um this
perect that is a good good solution for
pipeline it's not for data pipeline it's
uh it's like a flow it's like Jin you
can uh execute commands on Linux execute
function python function is good
solution but not for data there are no
way to handle meta data or life cycle of
the data Luigi is a good solution
provided by created by Spotify there are
not too much maintenance as I seen when
I choose to to go to DX because Lu is
there are not too much man no not many
teams and company that use it but it's
good solution if you want want to check
it
[Music]
so uh let's let's compare Al flow and
daxer so Daxter is focused on assets
assets it's what uh the data in general
want to focus the transformation of the
data is inside the asset assets are data
are table data frame whatever you want
but it's our
Focus
Daxter it's it has also a development
life cycle so uh you can create unit
testing you can create continu
integration you can separate the
dependencies of every pipeline you
create in our flow it's bit bit
difficult to do we we deploy the stuff
that it's horrible for for separated
dependencies uh we can debug uh we can
separate the staging environments
everything about this and there are many
different kind of deployment for
duxter uh whatever you want kubernetes
Docker AMR
everything
so let's maybe take a look at knar
maybe
so what
okay uh yeah this is a normal Asset
definition inductor so we have a we have
two three things to talk okay first
thing the cative pipeline code it's
finally that that we can create Pipeline
with clean code without spaghetti code
or stuff like this declarative code with
asset with this with just declaring the
parameters and the the the parameter and
also the ins it means what are you
searching if the data source is the
table and the datab basic on the on the
table B you can declare here you can say
okay the database is there the source is
there and the schema is
this you can create the dependen so you
define an asset that have another asset
as a dependence and you can run this
asset without the dependency
before you can create multiple
dependencies and you the asset it's just
an object that is stored in in a storage
whatever you want S3 SQL light SQL
whatever you want asset is just a object
so you can do an asset for your machine
learning model you can data frame your
DBT model whatever you want
so where where is the the magic where is
the magic inductor for my opinion is IO
manager IO manager is where where the
magic alen uh duer have many many and we
will see later that many I managers
already created like B queries fake data
brakes uh rash shift AR pandas
everything so you can handle all the
data that you want all the data source
that you want just just take the the I
manager provided by dxer just pep
install and it's fine but in my opinion
if you want to create different data
source different data serving and stuff
like this you can create your IO manager
and it's very easy there are two
function that is important and the
output and the load input and inside
there you can specify your Dynamic
partition partitioning of your assets U
multiple Source FP
s request to API whatever you want you
can retrieve the data from uh different
data source and the the special things
is that here you can Define the
metadata the metadata is what we want to
see on the dashboard
the metadata is what for example the
schema The Columns that we injust from
the table so maybe today the table in
just six columns tomorrow it's seven so
the manager say what
happened and I I can say in yes so in
the dashboard I can show the metadata I
can customize metadata if I want to show
the weer in in San Francisco I can say I
can just
write and I I can also C it Store It
Whatever and also here I can also
customize it a little the data source
type so if we want to have different
data source typ pandas and Spark in the
same IU manager we can specify the key
on the the key on the asset we just
Define on the asset here on the
declarative the key so whatever for
example SQL type post gr or MySQL you
can spe specify here and after the
manager it will
handle
so a good thing is that we we work with
big data so big big big it means
terabyte terabytes of data and uh if you
want to handle terabyt of data you need
to partition your data so it's very
important for us uh in a lab but in
every company that works with spark and
stuff like this and uh for this reason
we need to partition the data and the
asset can be do so an asset can be run
for one partition or for each partition
or for a range of partition buet you can
bucketing also your asset by partition
you can schedule a job by using an
interval of partition for example so so
imagine that you you want to run the
asset only for today and tomorrow so the
asset run only for this two days
partition we can create job partition so
we can Define the partition not only for
one asset that it's just one table just
one object but for multiple
assets and we can handle also
multi-dimensionality partition so like
time
and location for
example so as I explained before what I
what I shoose when I show tax the
declarative so it's very easy to
understand here which is the input of
this asset and which is the output of
this asset okay and you can see it from
the
dashboard you can see what what's going
on on the pipeline on the job on the
asset
you can see in the in which in every
layer of your transformation what happen
the dashboard in the dashboard you can
uh debug your pipeline you can
materialize your asset materialize it
means that you run the asset and it
persists the object on the storage the
storage is completely whatever you want
as
Sprint uh in the dashboard you can see
the partition that you are running
everything there are some things about
daxer also in the the last release about
graph uh from the the team of daxer
there is a suggestion to if you want to
use many many assets multi- dependencies
and stuff like this it's it's for
suggestion for scalability of the dxer
it's better to scph it's a Liber inside
AER to to handle multi multi asset multi
graph so mization back fing and sensor
as I explained mization it's the it's
the concept is the the event that uh
that trigger the asset so you run the
asset or maybe the asset already uh have
a storage with already the data loaded
everything and you don't need to reload
it so you can use cas the data it's your
you can customize it you can do it as
you
want sensor sensor are event so you you
create sensor for example if you want to
understand uh if you want to run a
pipeline every time there is a a new
release of a software yeah you just make
a sensor the sensor run every 50 second
everyone you want and check if this is
SQL uh data is updated or the API is
updated whatever you want and you uh you
can uh launch the asset or the pipeline
back
failing for partition of subset of
partition so when you when you
materialize the assets you you want also
to maybe make come
back because the data is wrong today
because the the the data source is wrong
so you want to come back what you do you
can do back filling for specific
partition or a set of partition so
you in follow you can do
this job and scale that it's uh what
it's in common with with pipeline job
are uh uh the aggregator that take all
the assets so you Define assets you
Define the dependency by asset and you
associate this asset to a group a group
of assets this group asset can can be
passed to a job to create a job the job
it's the the thread or
that um that is ruled to start the first
asset shoes which are the dependencies
and the sched of the of the of the
assets and so the job can be launched in
a different environment so imagine that
we have a server here and we have a
server in another country we want to
launch the
pipeline here with a set of partition
and there with another set with the Run
launcher and job you can do so you can
run the job in different server
different
environment uh by using the same code so
we we are not defining different code
the same code just say Okay run launcher
Docker or HS or WS whatever you want in
another
server and the SCH yeah sorry the is the
the main rule of the is to create the
rule for Crone for schedule the job so
so if you want to run it uh 20 time in a
day you can do it and there is a
policy uh that that you can create for
schedule the the pipeline the job in a
different in a dynamic scheduling so for
example if you want to launch the job as
I explained before with a sensor you can
do it by defining this
policy deploy and your PC as I explained
before you can deploy de Loy the
pipeline in different uh in different
server and run it in different country
with different data rulle privacy and
stuff like this how we can do this by
two concept this the repository
repository is where your pipeline is
located workspace is the older Pipeline
and older repository place so the
workspace it's uh it's not the the rep
repository in GitHub or gitlab or
whatever you want workpace is the
repository for all the pipeline of your
company or your team for example
repository instead is just for your
pipelines so I create pipeline Stefan
will create order pipeline in another
repository in another GitHub repository
and we can separate the dependency so I
have a dependency Stone have another
dependence so we we can work
independently
we can do it by using the grpc server so
the grpc server just connect the
workspace to the location of the code of
your repository so my code is in gitlab
your code is in GitHub so the jpg just
Connect into different and take the code
from
there so as I explained there are
launcher you
it's launcher that launch the the code
the PIP whatever you
want and so the the Magic The Magic
think of the modern data stack dxer
start their project by uh by defining
that they want to to use modern data s
and so DBT DBT is the first integration
that they created so with DBT you can
create easily uh data manipulation
pipelines and this is the call of that
data pipeline to monitor the data the
life cycle of the data so D have
integration on DBT you can use D TB or
you can use whatever you want to to run
it you can choose or you can do your IO
manager and handle all the all the data
source writing getting
everything and yeah there is this method
that's very easy to take
it
h like set of many integration ibite F
TR duxter spark twio whatever you want
they release integration every every
release or stuff like this so now they
have for example a new integration with
weight and bias for track the the life
cycle of the model it's it's not like ml
flow but it's similar stuff like this
you can register your model stuff like
this
thank you very much thank you for your
attention so big round of applause for
Ricardo yeah
yeah